I thought it'd be a good idea for me to
go have a mammogram when today ended I
had been diagnosed with breast cancer
[Music]
my name is Jenny garden and I'm cancer
survivor I was diagnosed on December
first 2011 one of the early experiences
I had as a patient in 2012 I went in for
a chemo infusion one of many and a woman
from billing came and got me in the
waiting area before they hooked me up
with the IV and she told me that my
insurance company was investigating me
for fraud the thinking on the part of my
insurance company was but it was likely
that i had lied about that a
pre-existing condition of cancer under
the law of the time they could have
terminated my insurance policy and I
could have received no cancer treatment
at all the biggest benefit for me from
the Affordable Care Act was knowing that
I wouldn't have insurance and access to
health care taken away from me as a
punishment for needing it in the first
place for many people in our country the
Affordable Care Act is just this very
strange abstract politicized football
that people are kicking back and forth
but for people like me the Affordable
Care Act is life or death I've seen what
it's like i SAT by the bedside of a
woman who lost everything before ACA
who's dying of metastatic disease that
maybe she wouldn't have had if access to
health care had been around for her I'll
never forget what her last days were
like and what what that it was like I
was looking at what could happen to me
and but it could happen to a lot of us
and it doesn't need to health care is
life if i don't have access to ongoing
medical treatment my disease will return
and kill me that's what cancer does I
didn't know why insurance really
mattered before I was diagnosed with
cancer I can't expect
other people who haven't walked a mile
in my hospital flippers to understand
what the ACA means for me here's what it
means it's just a little bit of
protection against being completely
destroyed by the cost of cancer
treatment surprise has happened and the
surprise that I got was a really big one
for many people the ACA is a hashtag not
for me